the era of virtual reality is here and  if you're looking to pick up Sony's  PlayStation VR headset it's going to  cost you how much research group super  data predicts anywhere from 400 to 600  dollars Playstations and your house  already said the headset would be priced  like a new console but a ps4 will only  run you 350 bucks it seems we'll have to  wait for official word from Sony and  that should come soon considering the  PlayStation VR is scheduled the launch  in the first half of 2016 PlayStation VR  isn't the only headset on the market  oculus rift pre-orders open January  sixth they'll cost you six hundred  dollars a pop and that's without a pc  that can run it if you're one of 36  million ps4 owners you'll be able to run  PlayStation VR right out of the box  that's the good news and for more news  you're already in the right place